hey gang welcome to the ru garbage
comedy podcast
please make sure you subscribe that way
you get the episodes as they come out
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast this is are you garbage it's
a show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we found out they grew up
classy
or if they're just a big old piece of
trash i'm your host stage foley coming
at you on a beautiful day
we're down here at aunt toddy's basement
she's getting excited for easter you
know she's a hardcore catholic
she already started to do the eggs
hiding the eggs around the house okay
but she doesn't use eggs she uses those
little airplane bottles of
goldenschlager oh nice
and we usually find them in a room so
it's a good time too
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he is the
ceo of ru garbage he's really an
international businessman
when it really comes down to it he is
the proud owner of a brand new pre-owned
kia
no it's not pre-owned it's not pretty
your own brand new 21
it's a 2021 baby damn check the books
t-bone
we're doing all right over here guys
moving merch give it up for kevin james
ryan everybody hey gang thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure you
review subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube and those numbers
are
true to roof [ __ ] cooking on youtube
uh and then obviously patreon.com you
can sign up to get premium content
bonus episodes at ayg yeah which people
are hitting up they didn't know they're
episodes that just live on patreon we
don't release those anywhere else so
that's bananas yeah
people aren't sure what's going on so
you can go there you get hard feelings
you can get
live streams where we play with ayg with
you guys it's a good [ __ ] time
good times get involved baby thank you
kippy and have a nice shout out to our
producer
extraordinaire the pride of the chicago
comedy scene
he works the ones and twos he's the
magic man he makes us all look pretty
give it up for t-bone mcmuffin toby
mcmullen
what up team we are turning into morning
zoo
more and more as we go on make sure
you're calling to get those van halen
tickets kids
we got a bank full of drops i got my
finger on the trigger it's forget we're
just becoming characters of ourselves
oh it is what it is and gang we could
not be more excited and i mean that we
could not be more excited to have our
incredibly special guest here with us
today
she's an extremely funny podcaster and
blogger she's one of the stars over
there
at the bar stool sports universe and of
course the co-host
of because we got high but the big
question about his mind today is she
garbage
looks very classy yeah but i can't get a
read
she carries herself well it does it
doesn't mirrors gentlemen i will tell
you that right now and can i say also
that was a fantastic intro
wonderful thank you so much activated
smiling ear to ear so much so that like
my cheeks are now because i was smiling
too much that was
great ladies and gentlemen that's kelly
keegs give it up for everybody look at
that
here i am awesome this yeah this is uh
well we've had other we've had a good
amount of bar stool people in here at
this point yeah i've been hearing that
or ten i don't even know how many
watched uh i watched the friday night
pints you guys were on
a couple weeks ago or last week whatever
and dice i know that you kind of went
down the list of people that you talked
to and that majority of people are
garbage
everybody was gone to joining them so
yeah i think you're i think you're going
to fall in there
i think so i know i thought this would
be an interesting one too now the more i
think about it the more
the more fun it seems uh give us the
whole back story give us the origin
story of kelly kings
first of all is that your is
so yeah just irish as [ __ ] like the
whole thing going on but why'd you go
with keegan
giggs is a name that my mom used to
always have written on like the side of
her
uh nursing school books like as if to
like you know so nobody would take them
i guess i don't know
and i always thought it was cool like
ooh keegs and then apparently that was
like also my dad's nickname and then
once
in gym class and like the second grade
my teacher said like kelly keegs
off-handedly and i it just kind of stuck
through so that was your nickname all
through
not not forever but it kind of like as i
got older it started being like oh kelly
keegs and then now
on the internet yeah it's it's firmly
stuck on the internet
yeah yeah good night it worked out for
me i didn't have to make it out for
myself
but keegan's good too keegan is good too
i i've got one of those names that
people they say your full name all the
time so it's double k's or like
double names it's like a superhero
writer yeah peter parker they always say
your full [ __ ] name so i get kevin
ryan all the time hey what's up kevin
ryan
yeah it's not a [ __ ] job interview
what are we doing yes every time every
time i'm never
never kelly always kelly keegan what's
your middle name ann so [ __ ] boring
and with an e and with an e also irish
so far
i'm kevin james patrick ryan yeah that's
a tough look
damn damn my brothers my brother is
samuel joseph keegan that's his
he's pretty that's pretty good yeah
we're irish and polish that's our mix
that name comes with the gout that's
tough right there irish and polish isn't
a great mix no it's not
that's like that's that's a little bit
of russian a little bit no it's a
nightmare
that's from my nana side she's always
like oh the russians like she'll talk
about
man especially after dinner a couple of
drinks are flowering
nice argument in the kitchen god i love
it forget it uh so where did where'd you
grow up yeah
jersey yes i did yes i did in jersey um
i grew up in north plainfield which i
don't know if
that's is that like central it's like
central yeah i want to say it's
pretty it's seedy it's a city area it's
not so much
now i would i i was born 1990s when i
was born and um my parents had a little
house
on samford avenue in um north plainfield
and i went to
saint joseph's catholic school which is
right around the corner
because it was the only place i could go
that was like okay
everything all the public school system
was like too much crime and like too
much stuff so i could only go to this
one place
and i was there from kindergarten
through second grade and um i think i
was brainwashed there that's the thing
i've i've now
started saying i think that i was
brainwashed are you crazy yeah
like i think that that's that's what
happened there that's catholic school
yeah [ __ ] was weird and so i grew up
there but then in the third grade we
moved out to flemington new jersey which
is
very funny yeah which is like those
those are the outlets the set outlets
that we've talked about
[ __ ] liberty village my brother my
brother my brother
shout out to the polo my brother worked
at polo forever
thanks for coming by we appreciate it
liberty village premium outlets if
anybody needs to roll through
yeah there's a kate spade outlet i
believe there was a lot that was like an
adventure [ __ ]
there was also a school bat or like a
luggage place that's probably still
there oh burlington co-factory no no
it's just like this stand-alone luggage
flemington department store there's
several
there's several it's a [ __ ]
standalone luggage would you guys go
would your family go
since you live out there would you guys
go to the outlets yeah
i mean that was like where we shopped if
we weren't going to the mall that's up
to savings
what the [ __ ] it would depend on what we
would go for we'd go there for certain
things like we would always go for j
crew obviously
because like i just pretended i was rich
and so i would shop discount jake
like factory so i was at the polo yeah
so i would do that and then polo for
sure um i think like brooks brothers was
also there i'd maybe buy like a bracelet
and be like it's brooks brothers
they were nice like they caught like
yeah it was like oh yeah that was they
were like the nice outlets
everything was painted white and it was
like a little campus yeah yeah
it's cute in there but it's but it was
definitely like not
people who went there definitely thought
they were richer than they are like it
was just that kind of [ __ ] i was pulling
up in my 96 chevy illumina yeah
yeah but the outlets weren't a thing
like when i was when i was younger i
don't know when we started going there
but when i was younger it was always the
mall bridgewater mall was the only place
we went to
and um it was like we lived our lives in
spencer's
uh we would go to claire's first maybe
if depending on
the group of girls i was with and then
we would like go to spencer's look laugh
at the sex toys and then go like creep
around outside the movies as long as we
could that was our
that was our suburban that was some [ __ ]
i just didn't know if you guys didn't go
to the outlets like people who like live
in vegas who don't go to the casino
they thought that was like touristy i
mean that was that was a pilgrimage well
the town is so small that it's like it's
it's just it's practical shopping like
it's not
there's not a lot going on out in
flemington what sucks about the outlets
especially with the family discount
you're losing money not going oh my god
well my brother's working at polo every
christmas the entire time it was just
like polo out the ass and my brother was
like yeah like
merry christmas to [ __ ] everybody and
it was fantastic that's awesome we never
thought to do that [ __ ] to get somebody
on the inside
oh yeah no no i worked at macy's dude my
brother told me a story
my brother told me story once about the
about the polo outlet that they used to
like train them ahead of time to kind of
recognize who the people were buying in
bulk people who seemed to be just coming
through and then gonna probably go to
canal street or something here
and um and they would come in and they
would just buy like
15 of the same shirt and like different
sizes and stuff like that my brother who
i think at the time was like 18 was just
like excuse me
i don't know what i can do about this
like some sort of like
you're the first line to the line of
awkwardness and you're also not allowed
to um you're not
like outright say it so you have to be
like are like are you sure you want all
these sizes like you have to be
like you can't just yeah you can't just
accuse them yeah but that was a huge
problem he said especially on like um
which we'll call it uh black friday
black friday yeah
what do they care i guess it's it's
because the resale [ __ ] i don't know
it's probably corporate cares like i
don't know
yeah my brother some 18 year old kid
he's supposed to be the first line of
defense
straight yeah some kid from flemington
taking on canals
literally tough very very tough for him
but no the the outlet thing was not it
was never weird
for us to go like i also didn't think
about them as we would say like we're
going to the outlets but
not in the way yeah it was always like
oh we're going to j crew like i'm headed
to j crew and it was always assumed it's
going it's the outlets
and that was that wasn't headquarters it
was like going to the mall i was like oh
are we going to the mall are we going to
the outlets like it's one we are right
in the middle of both
gotcha i thought it was fancy that's how
i guess that's because we're trash so
did we
not that i would like brag i'm like yeah
it felt fancy at the time because
there's like a little coffee shop in
there
like there's a nike store those are i'm
telling you those are the nice ones and
we sell we're going to oh we're going to
that one
like coat and tie other ones yeah you
know there's levels to that there was
there were a couple of jewelers in there
i think
like a roman jewelers maybe might be in
there i think i got a watch like link
taken out there one time thought i was a
billionaire
i got a watch
would you mind taking care of this phone
still ask her a box in a bag so you can
walk out with devices
of course i'll tell you what it those
nice places though you do feel like a
better person when you're walking out
with like
because their bags are nicer yeah they
have like a rope handle bag
it's like thicker you know it's not it's
not just the regular uh sure it's not
gonna rip on the ground
you know it's no brown bag in here it's
like a little bit thicker like canvas i
went to lugers on sunday and they're in
there to go bags i've been walking
around with that for [ __ ] four days
yeah
it's like my new purse that's how i
carry my [ __ ] around
yeah i'm hitting the beach with that 100
for real don't throw that [ __ ] away
never i would never oh my god i have
so many bags that are sitting in my
house right now that are like too nice
to throw away
i have tote bags out the ass and i wish
that i i started throwing them out
as of recent just yeah i still feel
guilty for wasting
obviously i'm a big fan of the new the
whole even at the grocery store those
bags they give you now
yeah yeah those like those like reusable
toasters like a plastic bag they're like
literal
bags that you can like pack your lunches
you're like a dollar i get them every
time we're just gonna
have so many we're just going to be
careless with them don't people really
know what's crazy too is that like i
know trader joe's specifically like you
have to buy that bag though it's like a
dollar or something and i always wear it
for sure but then they'll be like oh
which do you want i'm like wow now it's
now i can like pick something out
i chose one with like an owl recently
sure i see something in black yeah
automotive couple of pumpkins on there
i've been carrying around my owl bag
with like other [ __ ] in it
it's like what is this we all know this
is a trader basketball trader joe's bag
you all have seen it yeah we all know
trader joe's is like the whole foods
outlet
yeah it is yeah so much barebow it's
like the factory
they're great with the [ __ ] that they
mix up themselves like they're pre-made
stuff
yeah yeah i've never even seen that
before it's fantastic either have either
salsa is good they have their own sauces
and [ __ ] yeah
they kill it what is your uh so what'd
your mom and dad do okay so my mom
um when i was growing up she was going
to nursing school and she
is now like a nurse practitioner at the
er
in flemington nice and she's like
studying to get her
doctorate i'm like bitching this but
that's definitely what she's doing she's
been in school for like
i think the entire time i've known her
like she has always been like trying to
just she's always been doing something
and getting some of the degree and like
expanding her education so she can
like get promoted about pops my dad is
gonna do something
yeah my dad has always been involved in
he was like an accounting major
and then he's always been involved in
insurance he worked for blue cross blue
shield for a long time
and um and then he moved to this other
place called extensis which i have no
idea what it even is about
just like [ __ ] that i'm like i don't
know what this is but also neither does
he like he has no idea what this is dude
a place called extensiveness no one
is up to something right nobody knows
what their what that's up to
and then um and then now he like manages
benefits
through like a company that is in
flemington and it helps out like
uh insurance for other businesses and
things that's like what he's doing white
collar yeah white collar guy
does well it's a couple of bucks would
you guys say you grew up with a little
bit of cash or
not at first definitely definitely not
the later yeah in the later years for
sure
so my brother and i are seven years
apart and so um
the first like seven years no not so
much you know
probably not but then once we moved to
flemington it became a little it was a
little different so they both came from
humble beginnings as well very much so
yeah gotcha
i would say all right pretty cool okay
i like you grew up in a single family
home i assume out there like a suburban
house yeah so uh let's see the north
plainfield house was like more of a
townhouse
um she says things very classy i know
you're very so well trained so it's it's
bananas
i'm trying to figure it out amount of
movies that i've watched to like learn
like i'm a super ocd kid like i was a
[ __ ] weirdo like
basically basically like i was like i
never want to talk about the bronx again
like i'm going to become
this millionaire like i'm serious trying
to marry a senator over here
truly but um the north plain but no so
i'm trying to think like uh
exactly what so that house was it was
definitely like a
there was two bedrooms upstairs but my
parents first lived up there
and i was in this like side room which
was a bedroom but in retrospect
i don't even like it it wasn't a bad it
wasn't a bad like it was definitely
something else
a little lower or something there's an
angle
yeah angled angled over where i was
sleeping there was angle it was hanging
on both sides and then
my bedroom and then my parents like put
an addition on the house
which was just like a living room
basically and once that happened my
brother was born and he moved into the
tiny room that i was in i moved into the
room that they had
which was also upstairs which was a
similar slant situation but definitely
bigger like that was probably the
biggest room i ever had like i was it
was
most of the top of the house which seems
crazy but like i had my own
like it had like a carpet i like fit a
whole bed in it compared to what i was
sleeping in sure you were sleeping
this is [ __ ] crazy where'd your
parents go where'd their room they move
their room
downstairs into this like side yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i know but they
moved it to this like the side room it
used to be like the den
and then it became their room and it's
garbage and it's
and that was their thing the first floor
bed and i like and i can't really
remember like ever going in there once
they did that like i was always in there
when it was upstairs
i was like what is this room and we had
this like addition
and that's where and then it was just
the living room and an office and my dad
like put all his [ __ ] in the office
and then like my mom was always studying
or working nights or something
and um i just that was it i if i were to
draw the house and like know the square
footage i don't i think it'd be like
very small so i always think like it was
kind of a townhouse
and then my brother was born like i said
and all that you know we just kind of
crammed in there
and we moved to our new house which we
my parents still live in we still have
now and that house is was exponentially
bigger like we just
the house itself isn't so big we live on
like three acres
of flat it's just flat though like
nothing there's nothing we didn't like
we didn't do anything like it's just
flat as [ __ ] we've had that but that's a
tough look three acres and no pools yeah
do you have a trampoline or something we
have we how about a koi pond after like
years of me begging for a trampoline we
got a trampoline um
and it's it obviously crashed through
because the snow we left it out there
now it's gone but what we had in our
backyard we had a fire pit my dad built
that
not too shabby i loved that i think we
used it maybe
like once or twice a year during the
summer possibly
and then um a swing set also that was
like half a mile away like it was near
the woods yeah you put it like all over
my dad was like i'll put it over here
like for the kids and it's like if i
went out to the swing set my parents
like i could have been kidnapped like
they would never have call when you get
there yeah
that's it wait hold on there's three
acres when you say
it's it's is it is it grass is it like
it's grass just looks like a huge
backyard one big plot of land my house
is in the middle and that's it
and then so then there's woods behind it
and there's woods behind it yeah
what does your trampoline have the
protective netting or
had the netting on it only because my
mom was a nurse and she was like
the only way we'll get it she's like
because i've seen every single kid crack
their [ __ ] head open on the side of
the trampoline i didn't want the net
either though i was like i'm gonna
bounce my friends off the trampoline and
i wasn't allowed would she actually say
it like that was that
yes um she would curse when she was
really mad she curses more now because
i'm trash now so she like curses more
now but yeah she's going
to have curse as a kid no okay no i was
not allowed to curse as a kid
but i would like i would anyway oh i'll
tell you a funny story
once um i was playing hot potato with my
parents
and we it was just like my parents also
i think back uh
drank a lot more than i they drink a lot
now like they always have a drink
exactly hot potatoes they've always been
drinkers they've always been drinkers
but i i think of them now and how they
drink now and i drink with them and i'm
like oh yeah we're [ __ ] up and i'm
like
i don't know they've been drinking this
whole time like they've been drinking
like this always
and so when i think about these stories
i'm thinking when i'm younger i'm like
oh no you were drunk
[ __ ] up so we're playing off potato
which i don't know if you guys know it's
like a it's just like the hot potato
basically from toy story looks like it
and you squeeze it and you toss it back
and forth and then eventually it gets in
your hands you don't want to
ah hot potato you don't want it yeah you
don't want to get you don't want to get
you want to get stuck
is it hot no no no it just like makes
noise
yeah it's weird but it's stressful so
you like do the whole thing and i was
like an anxious kid
no idea why and so i'm throwing it
around and i kept losing and i was i
want to say like five or six
yeah and i lost at one point and i was
like god damn it like in front of both
my parents and like record scratch
they're like what did you say
like spanked sent my room whole thing
and then i had to write
out on paper three different pieces of
paper college ruled my mom
got it from like her school [ __ ] maybe
right like i will never curse
i will always clean my room like i will
always do this and at first
i tried to do it like big space like i
tried big over all three
and i got reamed out for that had to
redo it it was like a crazy punishment
for saying goddammit so no i
never like i never passed them they run
a tight chip yeah but then but then my
brother
no yeah the younger i was the youngest
and it was like by that point my brother
had blown through every [ __ ] rule and
it was
like as long as the cops don't bring me
home i'm all right exactly yeah that was
basically me yeah
that was a good thing about having uh
add when you were a kid i never got
those kind of punishments
like see that's nice my parents like
they didn't my brother has all that [ __ ]
now my parents were just me were like
snap out of it yeah like what are you
doing people also love how you were like
changing the font like it was a term
paper
oh yeah oh yeah you're like making it
yeah 4.5 times new roman double space
yes which in retrospect again my parents
are probably like this
[ __ ] like we're trying to like punish
this [ __ ] and i'm like yeah taking
shortcuts
yeah cutting corners who would i learn
that from you know let me ask you
something folks if you had a hole in
your water bed would you let it just
leak or would you fix it yeah you put a
patch on that thing that's right you put
a patch on that thing
but a lot of people all right a lot of
gentlemen when they have trouble in the
bedroom
they ignore the problem sure but you
don't got to do that anymore
if you've got something going on and you
need it fixed go to our friends at roman
if you go to getroman.com garbage you
can handle this problem
right now in the privacy of your own
home yeah guys it's the way to do it you
can go get a free online evaluation and
ongoing care for ed
all from the comfort and privacy of your
home baby what what
it's it's a no-brainer at this point a
us licensed healthcare professional will
work with you to find the best treatment
plan for you
tailored directly for you if
medication's appropriate it'll ship
right to your door
free two-day shipping out the door
forget about it
privately the whole process is very
straightforward very discreet
very easy nobody's got to know it can be
our little secret
you know take care of your ed without
ever leaving your home complete an
online visit today and connect with a
healthcare professional to help you take
care of it
go to getroman.com garbage yep
slash garbage baby and you'll get 15 off
your
50 i'm sorry correction 15
off your first month whoa forget a
percent baby we're talking cold
hard money 15 bucks off your first month
it's really time to take care of your
e.d and remember get started today and
you'll save
15 clams off your first ed treatment
go to getroman.com garbage folks real
quick
want to talk to you about the good time
that old uncle hank and the kip
kipparino are having there on the stereo
app usually every thursdays at nine
o'clock come join us
for a good time yeah guys if you don't
know by now get involved it's a good
time go to www.stereo
kevin ryan or slash h foley the link's
going to be in the description
easy peasy you click up we you click you
sign up we get to wet our beaks a little
bit
it's a good time we hang out we have a
couple of beers we answer your questions
live
on the show your garbage questions it's
like an after party to the actual
episode
so sign up in the link today now back to
the show all right let's get in a little
are you garbage here what do you say
kippy let's do it
let's uh let's start with some of the
basics now what was the name of the
street that the first house was on
she said sanford avenue one 190 sanford
avenue which sounds great but it sounds
classy
yeah but i i wish we could like google
earth it like it was not i
promise it was not i don't know why it
was it was called that but yeah that
wouldn't show up on google earth
yeah probably not like i have no idea
you don't want to come to that house
yeah the house doesn't exist anymore i
don't know where that is now
okay uh what did you get on your sats oh
my god
i have no [ __ ] idea um yes you do
no i really do because it was bad like
it was i don't know if
i want to say 1350. oh that would happen
but i don't know that was out of 2400. i
think so yeah yeah yeah you're younger
than sound really [ __ ] stupid yeah
i remember thinking like oh i know my
[ __ ] but then
then i did yeah 1300 out of that is not
good it's bad
yeah it was all english stuff like it
was like math i basically failed the
entire thing and it was just english and
writing was the only points that i
scored yeah
what about your gpa what was your gpa
gpa was always like mid twos like
covering around there
baby anything math related like and
science related [ __ ] me up i am not
i am bad with numbers like i see them
and i'm like i can't [ __ ] do it
right there i want to say i like it i
think maybe maybe applying for colleges
i might have like kicked it up
just enough to like a two nine or a
three like i really pushed it and like
tried really hard and then i got into
school and kept it at like a tube did
you go to the school you wanted to go to
i went to i applied to two schools the
first school that i applied to was high
point where i did end up going only
because we visited it
and my parents liked it a lot and they
like i found out later
let in a lot of kids who maybe didn't
have great great gp
school high point university it's a it's
a joke school
school it sounds like a school out of
hell it's a joke school
masquerading method you're in trouble
right now it's in trouble right now it's
a joke school masquerading as like a
fancy school and that's what people like
forget
but it's full of like country club kids
who's like were able to fool their
parents into thinking like oh this is a
higher education
me meanwhile i was like this place i can
like dick around all day long sure
it's fun my parents also recognize that
and like
and like let me go i don't know how they
probably shouldn't have i definitely
didn't really get an idea
i've never even heard of that it's like
north carolina yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] louisiana it's in north carolina
they're in trouble right now because
it's technically like
they're calling it a luxury school at
this moment because there's like a
steakhouse at the school
and so again imagine my ass this isn't a
shopping center
no it's crazy it's crazy because they're
in trouble because they're like campus
has a
and i just steakhouse i just was like oh
this is normal like none of it was
normal i don't know i intended i was
someone i wasn't for four years and
that's why i
am i heard there's a uh i heard there's
a really good texas roadhouse in notre
dame
well so what's funny about high it high
point the town
is like awful like high point the town
is terrible now it's better because of
the university but like
the reason there's a steakhouse on
campus is because the steakhouse they
try to plop it in the middle of the city
and it would just get like looted every
night so they'd be like all right let's
we'll buy your steakhouse if we can put
it inside one of our
things and then they taught us like
etiquette lessons at the steakhouse
like i learned what a namu's bouche was
at the stakeout the [ __ ] is that wait
why did you go there
why were you at the steakhouse it was an
intro because yeah it was like no
because it was a thing we could go every
week you could go once a week for a meal
swipe like you could go you had to make
reservations you had to like dress up
fancy
wait a minute like taught you how to be
fancy like that's that's literally oh
i'm turning i'm turning around
your cafeteria card worked at the
steakhouse once a week yes
what was it it was a magic meal it was
called i'm not kidding
you imagine it was what was like a piece
of stick wait what did you get like
a potato you obviously can you come into
the amuse-bouche which is a a
little taste for your palette to get
your get your glands moving
and then you would get an appetizer an
appetizer which could be like
tomato basil soup or like uh something
along those lines and then you would get
your main course i always got like a
[ __ ] filet
with you know you're like leon started
walks in both
yes very much so and then it would be
like you know garlic mashed potatoes and
whatever and then a dessert you get like
the molten lava cake or like a
cheesecake with chocolate or raspberry
drizzle or both if you're feeling crazy
like it was just me
playing pretend for four years like i
was a rich person that's pretty sweet
though man
i let you do that it was awesome what
was tuition there tuition was like uh
like
40 grand a year yeah okay that makes
sense
yeah it was a lot it was a lot and i
until this day i don't know how my
parents did it i know my mom was working
like three jobs at the time and like my
dad was you know just doing the same
thing like just trying to do whatever
and the fact that my brother and i are
far apart i think that helps
right they only were like you can have
several years yeah and when i went to
when we moved to flemington i was in
public school so it was like you know i
was probably schooled from third grade
till
graduation so it was kind of a i don't
know i still can't get over the [ __ ]
steakhouse
i always tell that part of it like the
whole place is absurd like if you look
it up online they were just in trouble a
couple weeks ago um because
people are like this place is excessive
and unnecessary and they and it makes it
like
it's too exclusive not a lot enough
people are let in and they're like yeah
because it's [ __ ] like
it's a school to learn how to be fancy
like you got to pay for it
if you don't want to pay for it then it
doesn't matter who you are like your
background but like
that's the whole point that's fantastic
so i think that i think i
lowkey my parents sent me there to like
be fancy luxury university but your mom
worked three jobs to get you there it
had a steak house in it
brother worked at an outlet store
brother worked in an outlet we're all
over the place i worked at a at a
jewelry store in my town like a local
jewelry store it was like a friends nice
on main street uh
i started at 16 worked through my work
through graduation
before that i babysat a lot like a nanny
that was the suburban
suburban girl thing yeah yeah yeah that
all adds up
okay but you you kind of have uh you
enjoy the finer things
right very much so um you're you're very
when i'm together
jewelry yeah you're very you're very
very very sharp together
very smoking very calculated you're
seeing me like we were we were like
filming stuff today so it's like i
dressed up the camera i took a shower
i hadn't showered since like i got off a
flight of california on tuesday and
before that i hadn't like i hadn't
showered since california so it's just
this morning so don't don't be fooled
okay well you when it's game time you
come through yeah yes very much so yeah
but that's a very interesting dichotomy
it's weird yeah the humble beginnings
yeah it's got some some weird [ __ ]
um what was the name of the grocery
store that your mom went to when you
were a kid
oh acme yeah i know that acne acne yeah
really yeah
playing field it's like in greenbrook or
whatever well i was talking flemington
flemington no
flemington was uh it was first it was
shop right
and then it became stop and shop because
it was like a little bit closer in
flemington but in north plainfield
it was acme all right put the air
conditioning units i've been on the roof
i put the air conditioning units on that
shop right
that's how trash we are what do you mean
i can't get a free bike
i put the train unit on there you know
who i'm with the shop right
that bait that it was like the
world-class shop right you know what i'm
talking about it's like off of 22. i
know exactly
i'm my family's company put the air
conditioning units on that shop right
that's amazing i was on the roof we
would go there like it was like we were
like it was nice
that was like that was like a premiere
one yeah we were we were also kings we
would
my dad would always go to kings or
bishops because they were closer
because they're not
up the road then it's available it goes
world class shop right that it was like
oh my god and then it was kings which
was in its own little outlet that also
had a rite aid so he could
double up there and then like a little
bit further up was the bishops and i
think that maybe their
sliced meats are cheaper because that's
the only place my dad goes like he goes
nowhere but bishops
and is that how you refer to it as
sliced meats um
what would you refer to that as cold
cuts cold cuts yeah yeah cold cuts
okay and she's garbage yeah yeah oh yeah
i think i'm like i think i'm only
garbage because i have like because all
of my
underlying like tendencies come from my
parents and they're a little bit garbage
now acme is a [ __ ] top shelf grocery
store is it but in the middle of the
road
no it's not it's garbage but they do it
right yeah they know
their deli counter is fantastic you're
going to be in there with other animals
but yeah you know what
you're getting the job done yeah it's
like a b-plus okay
um i like it let's see
if you're going if you go out to eat uh
and you don't finish your meal will you
take leftovers
this is big this is a big one especially
at the bar stool university this depends
um if you're at the face like 100
of the time yes it's mostly because of
like guilt of not finishing it i'll be
like oh no
like of course of course i'll bring it
in you don't want to insult them yeah i
don't want to insult anybody
also i mean we just always were like
told you gotta like don't you don't you
dare waste that wow
like pack it up or bring it in and then
will you re-eat it or will you throw it
out
um now as an adult now as an adult
sometimes it depends on like if i'm you
know high later that night maybe i will
but um as a kid yeah might we would like
heat up leftovers be like oh leftover
you know from apple oh yeah yeah shout
out to apple
tgi fridays the way around a [ __ ]
appetizer
i could probably no i could probably ugh
if i back in the day i could list every
single appetizer on the friday's
menu like we were we would crush fridays
afterwards
the jack daniels chicken strips chicken
strips the like the sampler with the
onions oh they know their way around
they really do they really do yeah i've
never had a potato skins i was like the
potato skins
potato skins they packaged and you would
do at home so we're fantastic they
really were and it was never good
the spinach fantastic
i get that from the freezer section a
lot i'm feeling like oh i want some
chips or something yeah yeah yeah
it's falling out of her now i love it
that's fantastic
you're trash by the way we haven't even
talked about it how stoked are you guys
for [ __ ] legal weed in new york
well that just passed today right yes
it's like as we speak i feel it's yeah
it's on its way
yeah something so we'll be able to go to
like a shop i'll be able to go to the
shop and get my eddies
you should be maybe not right away but
it takes a little bit of time like they
legalized it in new jersey
but there's nothing really happening yet
in new jersey that was like a couple
months ago i think maybe six
i don't know how many uh the time runs
together it's time to get in the game
yeah make some phone calls um do you
brush your teeth in the shower
no no really you think that's tragic i
don't do the um
i don't necessarily think it's trashy i
think it's probably a good like time
saver i
i just brushed my teeth outside i said
it very she said it very quickly yeah
i just never have thought to bring it in
there because then i gotta bring the
toothpaste in there it seems like too
much of a hassle i'd rather do like
i'm a little bit uh ocd yeah
you have a routine so it's not for gross
reasons you don't think
no it's just more so like i i'm focused
here on brushing my teeth and in here i
am focused on the shower
like i gotta wash my hair in here okay
also brush my teeth but i can see how
people think it's like a time saver it's
trash though
yeah wow one more one more big one
that's been going around
oh [ __ ] you get a bagel in new york city
uh-huh do you get it toasted
or untoasted um most times on toasted
excellent i do on toast is that is that
that if it's a proper bag
yeah yeah i'll do toast if it's like a
thomas bagel yeah yeah that's
that's the standard that's the stuff
yeah and that's like that's like how i
grew up thomas bagels yeah
did you guys do uh english muffins all
the time i feel like english muffins are
like uh
whatever i'm saying as far as people are
like what i'm like oh english muffin
like a little bit of butter a little bit
of jelly
the cinnamon raisin english muffin i
could eat the whole box delicious
like several occasions delicious i'm not
a big fan they were just
i don't know i liked the thing in new
york for a while they were doing
uh some of the pubs on the upper east
side were doing uh it was like
kind of a classy thing to do a burger on
an english muffin which is fantastic
i don't think i hate that they're tasty
oh so good yeah the english muffins are
pretty small i think i might like that
though because sometimes the buns are
like a little
i unless it's like a like a soft bun i
can really bite into sometimes it's like
a little
too much bun yeah yeah fantastic the
right answer there
okay yeah no pressing the keys in the
shower don't not toasting a fresh bagel
yeah you said you don't you'll take
leftovers home
i'll take leftovers home if i'm going i
will say this so i'm going right home
i'll take the leftovers and i'll
probably end up eating them myself
when like growing up and stuff i we
always would definitely take leftovers
what about we go out to dinner now you
order a bottle of wine
you don't finish it are you taking it
with you
that very much depends on where i am it
depends on where i am but most times i'm
not
i'm not leaving a bottle like i'm
finishing the wine yeah there's i don't
think i'm
i can't remember a scenario where i
didn't finish the wine bottle and i like
need to take it with me
but i think that i would sooner
no i would sooner pour it all of it in
there and like chug it before i
before i take it off she's a [ __ ]
class out yeah okay i can't do that
even money on the [ __ ] table yeah no
that's a never waste i'd never like to
waste not because i care about like the
environment it's the guilt thing it's
like i can't i can't believe i just
spent all this money and i'm wasting it
i don't mind wasting food i have
i'm very against wasting alcohol yeah i
would throw a [ __ ] i throw a [ __ ]
t-bone steak on the floor
before i before i left a half a miller
light on the table for sure dude
for sure that's kind of that's pretty
fair yeah pretty fair um
okay let's all right uh if you're going
to the liquor store it's just you no one
else
and you're like i'm going to make dinner
i'm going to order dinner whatever let
whatever it is
and you're going to buy a bottle of wine
for yourself just for yourself
okay what are you spending on that
bottle of wine um no more than fifteen
dollars
okay that's that's because it's i think
i think it's a total rip off
um most times i'll do somewhere between
like 10 and 12.
okay depends on that's on the lower end
i gotta be honest yeah yeah yeah that's
down there are a couple of i'm like a
wine person so there's a couple of wines
that are pretty good that don't the
hangover is what makes me want to spend
a little more money i
know my hangovers are so [ __ ] bad
that i can't i can't live
the other day we were um we were [ __ ]
around in central park and i was with
a couple of younger girls who showed up
with sutter home
like rose sure and i looked at it and i
was like oh good memories but also like
i'm gonna have a like a migraine just
looking yeah it's a lot of sugar in
there
so much sugar when's the last time you
drink wine out of a box
um probably not that long ago i'm i'm
not against like if it's there
she's got no shame in her game if it's
there i'll drink it like whatever who
cares
no hold on that 15 bottle of wine you
said would be for you
what if you're going to somebody's house
and you're and you're bringing a bottle
of wine i'll probably
do about the same because i feel like a
lot of people don't don't know like i
can i can just pull the
pull the tag off like i'm just gonna
take the label off
unless they're like a wine snob person
i'm gonna be like yeah do the same thing
you're gonna matt you're gonna match it
for sure
i also feel every time i've taken a
bottle of wine somewhere they don't like
open like it's like no they never do
that
they're like oh thank you and they
already had cause like they're having
people over so they went out and bought
five bottles of water exactly and
everybody brings wine you know what i do
what i do now i'm a part of this like uh
i have like taken some back with me like
if we didn't i've done that before
but um just as like a side thing like
i'm just gonna nobody took that so
that's a great flaw hold on what are we
talking about below the radar depends on
like who it is like if
everybody's batter that's true wait
we've talked about it if you
if you're drinking if you take wine and
you're drinking it and she doesn't
finish it she'll say
you go to a friend's house you bring
wine yes like say i bring a bottle of
wine
and maybe we don't open the bottle of
wine that i brought but maybe we're
drinking the same or something similar
and there's a lot of [ __ ] around maybe i
will bring that wine back with me like
depending on the situation or maybe i
didn't pull it out of my bag
or like maybe we did open it and i and
it's like we only had a sip it or i'm
the only one drinking it that also
actually happens more where i will bring
something
and i maybe want to drink that like i'm
always bringing uh prosecco or champagne
that's my favorite thing because people
want to drink it fast pretty classy but
they're just taking it over
no no it kind of puts pressure on people
to like because if you there's oh
champagne now all of a sudden it's a
celebration like let's drink this and
i'm the one that wants to drink it
so we'll open it i end up drinking the
whole thing myself and nobody
everybody's like switched to wine after
one glass and i'm like well this is mine
for the rest of the thing so it's a
little bit selfish in that way get back
to the steel in the bottles of water
situation you'll do it on the low so
you'll slide it into your bag
yeah i've done that yeah so like there's
a specific one called apothec red that
is super everybody like everybody knows
that wine like it's just a random one
it's like a
reasonable price and i think like three
people had brought
the same [ __ ] and i was like okay well
we just [ __ ] brought like we have so
much stuff like i brought this
nobody really saw me bring it like i
kind of just like threw it on the thing
and it was close to my thing and i kind
of swiped it on the way out
i mean i don't agree with it but i get
it i'm not
like proud of that move but when you're
[ __ ] broke like that
i was super broke at the time and i was
like it's breaking the bank
for me to bring this 12 dollar bottle of
wine to this place nobody's drinking it
we're all they have enough
like so much wine i get it you don't
have time
for them to have the wine in their homes
no no no if i'm going to someone's house
for dinner
i'm not bringing them a bottle of wine
for them to enjoy later yes you kind of
that's like what you're supposed to do
yeah we're going to a party we're
hanging out that's
this is what i started doing so this is
where this is where like being trash
like being trash and being like fancy
co-inside
i have signed up for this thing um this
like one it's like
it's a wine club but it's not a fancy
wine club it's just like a cheap
club and it's like 40 a month and it
will auto
take from your [ __ ] and then at a
certain point they're like we owe you
like you've been paying us
for so long like we owe you like 20
bottles of wine so they'll send you all
this wine
and then i have it in my house so every
time i leave i'm like oh whatever i'll
just grab one of these i'll grab one of
these and it all boils down
it ends up like being less expensive and
i've always got wine on deck
and so it's kind of like i don't have to
go to the store now and think about
anything like i'm
being lazy and also smart at the same
time what you're stealing from the
parties
man i know this is a this is like a
[ __ ] game of tennis baby
i'm so curious yeah i like don't really
cause i i mean
i know how i definitely trash i know
that for sure but you guys they already
are thinking
but you're like i belong to a wine club
but then i also steal the one it's like
every every question has a turn to it
you know yeah
man yep uh let's see about this one
kind of on the same path here have you
ever been asked or anybody in your
family
at any time growing up have you ever
been asked to leave a restaurant
not a bar a restaurant not a bar it has
to be dinner to leave a restaurant
or breakfast um breakfast whatever [ __ ]
was your family getting into
even ask you said the never ending
pancakes
that means never ending
[Laughter]
i know that i've been we've been asked
when i was younger
it was like a like a family party at a
restaurant does that count
like uh like a listening after like
after a christmas and you got that was
asked to leave and it was a
we were hanging out a little too long
and it was like okay like it's time and
people were drinking like too much
yeah yeah i've i've had those i've had
those where it's like
you know what actually here's there's a
boss boy waiting there with a baby for
you to leave you here's something
yeah yeah and your uncle's telling the
same story he's been telling for 30
years you're like one more time
exactly the baby's long gone i assume
kippy's family's been kicked out of a
baptism before the baby was driving
exactly yeah it's not not great here's a
story that i'll tell you that i'm gonna
i'm
like not gonna i hope my parents don't
listen to this because my mom will not
like this but
we should have been kicked out um my
grammy's funeral
uh okay my okay
at the at the funeral oh my god this is
like an awful story
no it's worse grammy is not a classy
name for grandmother by the way
i know that trust me i know that look
she can't take those rings with her yeah
so i pay for grammy so whatever so she's
chilling like yeah recipes
she's chilling in the casket like
hanging out and um my that's the side of
my family that's much bigger and they're
uh that's like more of like the polish
irish side big drinkers
and the dirt ball side yes yeah and so
we're there and it's like my mom is all
distraught like everything's happening
i'm feeling like responsible for some
[ __ ] because i'm one of the older like
kids and i'm kind of running around next
thing i know my
uncle and a couple of his friends who
were there
and like his wife and a bunch of their
kids uh tailgating in the parking lot
tailgating the parking lot and
tailgating yeah butt heavies
and we were they were just like out
there you know just chief and cigs
tailgating background
commenting like coming through sometimes
like coming in like for a minute then
going back out and i remember
thinking at that moment yeah because it
was like a wake it was awake for at the
funeral home so it was like literally
you know yeah no i know they're like in
the parking lot so it's the night before
the funeral right yeah
or no uh yeah yeah yeah yeah the day
like the day okay
morning before yeah i would say the
viewing is probably like between
you know noon and four like in that time
drinking out of viewing
uh-huh and so i remember my dad my dad
is like
he comes in and he comes to me and he's
like don't like point like make sure
your mother doesn't like necessarily see
that
and i was like oh well she's gonna see
it like they're screaming in the parking
lot but heavy she's gonna see it they're
throwing a football so i am like oh yeah
hold on when you say uncle it's the
it's her like son of the son of of my
deceased grandmother
holy her son [ __ ] yeah hey everybody
mourns in their own way
right right
my dad comes in my dad saw it he like
went out there i remember coming like
him
telling me like she keep it on the low
and i'm like i gotta see this
so i'm out there kind of creeping around
it's my cousins and [ __ ] and so i can't
go up and i'm like
what's happening here they're like oh
we're just drinking like we're just
drinking we're just hanging out
and they're talking about like like
sports and whatever just completely
taken away from the from the situation
and i remember thinking to myself like
i would actually love a beer right now
yeah but my mom will murder me if i roll
back in like i just had a bud heavy with
like you're
sure you know uh i gotta make a wawa run
real quick
but yeah that was a that was a wild a
wild thing that happened and we all just
kind of acted like it was no big deal we
were like all right my mom eventually
did find
out and was like pissed and thought it
was trash but then after that we didn't
we don't talk about it anymore i'm like
that was a crazy thing huh tailgating
the funeral let me ask you this do you
remember where the luncheon was
after the oh let's think
i think it was at because i assumed
people were it was like
chimney rock let's see it was like a
like a back room at chimney rock or
something like
which was kind of classy normally would
have been at charlie brown's which is in
uh
i don't know i've heard about it i don't
know i don't know i feel like charlie
brown's might be closed now but charlie
brown's was always the spot we went to
after christenings and after communions
and [ __ ] was always
that that was that was for the that was
lemon chicken out the ass family's
ordering the same thing is garbage
just family style lemon chicken love it
delicious
when my grandmother she got my her my
aunt's house was right across the street
oh [ __ ] because it was in it was in port
richmond sure so it was right across the
street and we just
everybody was like we kept making
excuses to go over to my aunt's house
because it was a huge thing we were like
it's a couple hours you can't wait till
now
to have a drink we're all in a [ __ ]
the back of a row home in port richmond
[ __ ] cranking bernie's
drinking coors lights all in like big
baggies and [ __ ]
look like steve harvey out there
holy [ __ ] not proud but what is what it
is
a lot of weird [ __ ] oh do you sleep with
the tv on
um almost exclusively do you sleep with
a fan on you
i used to but then um it started like
really drying me out so now it's
humidifier
okay it's classier it is but jesus is
there
but it gets everything it gets
everything soaking wet though the
humidifier like you gotta put a towel on
the ground and like make it go you know
it's just it's that close to the bed
like
it's on like my nightstand yeah holy oh
yeah [ __ ]
it's like sleeping in the rainforest
dude jesus kind of is yeah
the tv on the fan one last thing i'm
sorry the
how many pillows oh i got a million
pillows i used to
i used to have um like only two and now
i have
i want to say six i think
too many like two men i just feels like
luxury like
something about more pillows i'm like oh
here i am and all my pillows and i kind
of set them up
i know i set them up on my bed like i
have two like going diagonal in
two this way i have like the two smaller
ones like all of it it basically
makes an arrow that i put my body in the
middle and it's like i'm like the queen
of my own castle like that's the
situation
wow [ __ ] ton of pillows yeah um
have you ever checked into a hotel and
brought your own cooler uh yes
oh my god yes she's trash
almost like exclusively yeah i was like
if i'm with my family a hundred percent
of the time
you'll check in your family will check
my parents oh my dad has brought a
cooler
everywhere that we've ever gotten i
swear to god like i swear to god
my dad brings a cooler everywhere we go
because that's nothing to my mom
will only drink budweiser or uh holy or
pregnant
only budweiser or freshen a like the
black bottle like champagne
it's like it's twelve dollars delicious
it's amazing i love it
i mean she was looking at us like you
know what we're talking about we're like
yeah i was just trying to practice
making sure i couldn't get past the
heavies your mom's just drinking butter
heaviest
out the ass she will only drink those
things so if they go to a place and my
dad has now learned like
if there isn't bud heavy at the place
you got to bring a cooler for her
and then he'll like pack some coors
lights for himself but because he's not
very he's a gentleman
yeah shout out to the lybala de plata
he's not mr keys you're my kind of guy
not very picky so he'll do that but my
mom if she doesn't have like what she
wants like she
she'll like pout about it like she won't
ha she won't substitute it for anything
else they don't even have budweisers
my first the first things i ever drank
was like it was budweiser budweiser's
like
hands or bottles cans well actually no
i'm sorry sorry i should not lie
cans with my friends bottles my mom
exclusively okay your mom likes a bottle
she likes bottles only she refuses
cancer tell you what man an ice cold
[ __ ] budweiser
delicious yeah is delicious good night
um
what about vacations when you were a kid
where would you guys go nowhere jersey
shore
almost expected jersey shore um long
beach island my grandparents live at
classy
yes which is nice classic they they live
on um they live on a lake right right
before the bridge so it's okay
it's nice um but when we would go it was
always
seaside or point pleasant and we would
say
i don't know point pleasant that well
but seaside's [ __ ] trash see they're
next to each other they're like
basically they say point
is a little more family friendly but uh
barely like it's got a boardwalk as well
um but yeah we wouldn't do let's see if
we would go to the beach
uh my parents always wake up start
drinking once i was old enough to drink
same yeah
drinking eating then my dad would like
wake me up or make me come with him to
go pick out like a million of the shrimp
like we'd go to the weird place on the
corner yeah whatever the [ __ ] it was
called like los alas or something
seafood place yeah the seafood place
pick up a bunch of shrimp um
because that's all my mom would eat she
doesn't like any other shrimp and bud
cocktail sauce a [ __ ] ton of horseradish
like more horseradish better
um yeah i like it and and that's just
that's also now my taste i love shrimp
with this [ __ ] tonight
like horseradish and um we would do that
my dad would sometimes get himself like
a little bit of his own like white fish
but it was always burgers and dogs like
the whole that's all we would eat for
and potato salad background salad that's
yeah yeah where would you stay would you
guys rent a house or um in a hotel
we would rent first we had stayed at a
couple of hotels like early years but
then we would always get like a like a
house house like a turbo my dad
discovered like verbo
and that's what he uses exclusively now
cool so the houses were always
ended up being like kind of nice down
the shore for a week never disney world
disneyland we went to i went to disney
world when i was
um seven um my mom was like six months
pregnant with my brother
okay and it was my birthday and we went
for three days it rained the whole time
and uh my mom didn't go on any rides and
so it was like basically the worst
vacation that i ever went on
i remember bits and pieces had a good
time that's the most the most we ever
did
and when they say when your brother says
hey you never took me to disney world or
they say actually
you did go they say actually we did and
then i my brother and i went to disney
world just the two of us
when he was like a little bit older yeah
i know it seems weird
because my parents didn't want to go
again they were like that place sucks
i was did you drink at least i could
my brother couldn't um i'm trying to
think how old i was maybe like 22
my brother's seven years younger than me
i think so you were 22 yeah and you took
you took in the district
yeah that's nice no they like sent us
yeah
like we don't want to go like you guys
go because i i was like yeah i'll go
back i had a good time i'd rather
honestly go with my brother because he
would like do [ __ ] with me
sure it ended up being fine oh that's
pretty good that's a pretty that's nice
yeah that's wholesome it was it was
pretty hostile that's good
you and your 15 year old brother at
disney world that was probably [ __ ]
great no
parents we had a really good time yeah
it was like no parents like it was crazy
but um but no my parents wanted nothing
to do with it
you guys got kidnapped easily so easily
they didn't
i don't even think my my parents like
thought anything of it they're like yeah
take them whatever 22 still pretty young
to be responsible for sure
i can't believe they trusted me like we
stayed we had like a hotel room or each
of our two beds
and we would just like like i got him up
in the morning like we're going to the
parks extra magic hours like i treated
it like i was like
i was that [ __ ] yeah
when you went with your parents did you
drive or did you fly
um we flew but we stayed in
and i didn't realize that it was like
you know how they have um
disney has these resorts you only know
if you like know it well i think but
they have these resorts that are like um
uh you didn't stick with the budget
resorts like they're they are still
a part of the grounds but they're like
off a little bit yeah
they're called like like the like the
music spot and like this
sports i know what you're talking about
they're kind of like fringe they're not
like
the grand floridian or like the beach
club or like those places
it's the bush did you have to take a bus
or something to get to yes
yes uh every morning every morning and
it was like the la as far away as you
as possible so we'd like wake up a
little early get on the first stop on
the box
yes you were going to disney with like
like all the nurses going to work and
[ __ ]
for sure literally for sure and like it
was obviously you know i'm like grateful
i went but
you think back and you're like damn okay
that's what we were rolling with all
right yeah
cool cool right outside the gate no one
that your parents are like [ __ ] that
yeah no they they're right i'm not
flying to disneyland they never want to
do
anything they never want to do anything
and i'm like you guys it could be so
much better than this
you guys just like pick the cheapest
thing and you're like oh let's just go
do it and then it sucks it's like
obviously it sucks
yeah it's funny man that's fantastic
that's like we have a short my parents
just go down the shore and drink always
every week down the stretch
all they do is downstream and drink down
the
park their car and then never use that
they park it when they get down
they start drinking and then they move
it in four days or whatever my dad i
think is
yeah we just i don't know if he ever
abuses the car he likes to walk
everywhere and he'll like get up and
he'll just walk around the town as if he
like lives there
nobody knows you are here like you're
walking like a gym like everybody
[ __ ] knows you no one knows you're
here
you're just buying like two pounds of
shrimp
and [ __ ] two cases exactly yeah it's
crazy
did you guys ever do any like long
distance driving vacations
hmm i'm trying to think oh we drove one
time down to the outer banks
that was like that was a far drive it
was my my parents friends got one of
those houses where it's like
five families in one house and we drove
all the way down there and that was
a big deal we were like oh my god this
is a crazy different
you know just different beach different
beers and shrimps but like
i had to drive hey budweiser anywhere
maybe we had to drive 11 hours together
played rummy cube nonstop like i was i
was at that age i think at that point i
was like maybe 13 or 14
and so my brother was too young to
really play with and i was the only kid
like my age
were stuck at this house and i got like
sun poisoning the first day
and then and then fair iris yeah nobody
gave a [ __ ] about like what i was up to
they all drank all night long my brother
and like the younger kids played and i
just kind of
pushed around ah that sucks yeah yeah
because the multiple family vacation
though is completely garbage yeah is
absolutely
how i fantastic up every single summer
was a multi-family vacation yeah yeah
down down in ocean city new jersey oh
there you go ocean city ah dry town
tough
yeah stinks across the bridge yeah
refrigerator and they weren't good they
wouldn't
they might this squad wouldn't want to
go out to a restaurant and drink and pay
those prices
they're going to be doing that anyway
they're going to be loading up on booze
and bringing over 100
and drinking out of the back deck anyhow
we never went
to restaurants on vacation i don't
remember ever
rarely always grill whatever's on the
grill whatever was being made like
grilled chicken even like anything
whatever never
we would do like one or two dinners
maybe and
there was a hundred percent chance that
me and my brother ruined every single
one of those oh yeah
100 i'm sure spilling [ __ ] on the tables
getting in the fights
waiting in line for like an hour and a
half for the team i have a question was
um
i'm thinking back to the more
restaurants was ruby tuesday's fancy
for you guys ruby tuesdays to me like
felt fancy as [ __ ] like i was like that
is
when i was growing up like for sure i
was like whoa ruby [ __ ] tuesdays
i don't know fancy's the word but we
didn't [ __ ] with it because i don't
think they were really around right
there was a couple in the area okay but
we we looked at that one as the
overpriced one
yeah why are we going to go to ruby
tuesdays and go to apple we go to
[ __ ] fridays
that was my dad's mindset yeah so much
so that ever occasionally my brother and
i would like go to ruby two's
let's go to ruby tuesday yeah let's get
crazy
in your younger days were you a fan of
the salad bar
when they were around yes actually only
and i didn't even like like salad i just
thought it was cool to like pick
everything from the thing i was like wow
this is my own choice like i get as many
shrimps as i want i can put as much on
my plate as i can fit
but i was always stressed out that i
wouldn't like fit everything i wanted i
also don't like uh
i didn't i was better about it now but i
didn't like food touching so that was
always a thing like a problem for me
i'm i'm right there with you yeah wow
really yeah man
yeah it sucks my my parents used to
always give me [ __ ]
like my dad is somebody who just like
swirls it all around his plate he hates
it all at once
and yeah he doesn't seem too refined
like multiple no
i like multiple things on my feet yeah
that's the same with him but so he would
there was like a point in time where he
was like i swear to god purposefully
making me dinner plates and like putting
it all together like he was doing it on
purpose and handing it to me that way
and so i would just like eat in like in
circles and he would be like you really
are just not gonna just shove it up
no i'm not like i don't care how much
like gravy you put on this spaghetti
like i'm not gonna do it
it's ridiculous holy [ __ ] mm-hmm the
food not touching
the food's not getting i get it i got
weird still still my my dad gives me
[ __ ] for it he's like
you're an insane person i'm definitely
better about it now but when i was a kid
i was
it was like a problem i knew a kid in
elementary school that when he got his
lunch he would eat
each individual thing that's how i eat
now like on thanksgiving i eat like one
at a time
what what are you a psychopath on
thanksgiving all rules are out the
window
no no no hold on like i'll eat like all
the corn and then i'll eat all the i got
let's see all the corn first probably
the um
cranberry sauce next and then maybe the
stuffing
then the turkey maybe i'll i'll sprinkle
in some turkey while i'm eating those
other things and i always save mashed
potatoes for last
toby call the police holy [ __ ] do you
have a soundproof room in your house
no probably not well who knows maybe i
haven't been there in a while who knows
that's bananas i duct-taped their hands
first
that's psychosis i'm just waiting for
like the day when i wake up and i'm like
oh
there's that like memory ever press that
maybe this way like i'm waiting for that
day
i've yet to find it but i'm i'm trying
i'm smoking a lot of weed and i'm trying
to get there
i will i when i figure it out i will let
you guys know because it's
it's something deep and dark yeah that's
how i can find it bananas
yeah it's nuts i feel like i'm circling
mine a little bit
yeah you know what i mean i honestly am
and it has something to do with this
place
that i we we went to when i was a kid
that was kind of like the ymca
yeah but it was like it was a catholic
youth center that we did like
we do like this sounds like oh [ __ ] he's
like oh no not a catholic youth center
a man i know what goes down there i
didn't know any better back then
they do a different kind of backstroke
there yeah for real [ __ ] you know what
uh my dad told me a story the other day
that um i completely forgot about i was
calling him to ask him
on our because we got high pockets we
were talking about kids it was the k
each episode is uh corresponds with a
letter of the alphabet and we pick three
topics that are just with that letter
okay and the k episode had kids is one
of the topics and we were just going off
about like kids are annoying or like do
you want kids
and i called my dad to ask him how much
catholic school was when i had gone
and he was like oh back in the day like
i was probably like like 500
a month or 200 a month or something like
not so crazy and he was like but
the reason it was so inexpensive is
because i
they said to me the catholic school was
like if you host bingo night for us
a couple times a week we'll knock some
off of your kids tuition so my dad was
like of course because we're living
wherever live
yeah and um he would bring me and it was
just like old people smoking inside and
my dad like calling bingo and i have
memories of just sitting in like the
basement of the church
i think man like hosted at your house
like go to the basement of the church
and my mom would be like again
whatever you go my doubt i'm sure he
like loved it more than he lets on
because he's one of those
i'm sure
literally though and then there'd be
like old ladies yelling at him from the
audience
knock it off we know you don't have it
and then me sitting like also playing
bingo
here i am like h5 oh mr keegs is doing
crowd work i love it
any anything to anything to like fly to
the moon
yes anything to get a deal i used to do
that with my great aunt i would go and
sit and i would be with i would be with
her while she played bingo with all the
girls
smoking yeah of course yeah so much i
know that i like
i think that one day when eventually
they cut me open my insides are black
i'm going to blame it on that
instead of all the [ __ ] that i did and
yeah yeah yeah
i i only got a couple more i mean i
think we got her pretty dead to rights
at the moment
yeah uh she's gonna have to do a lot of
a lot of work in the fourth quarter to
get out of it yeah will you drink the
coffee in
a hotel room um i would if i like needed
to like if i if i was wanting to i'm not
i'm not a big coffee
coffee drinker oh you could have a a
million bucks i wouldn't like the
instant coffee you mean
i've like had it definitely yeah no
that's crazy
they say not to do that sometimes it's
like french vanilla flavored well it's
the machine
when you walk in damn yeah that's what
i'm saying
no yeah i don't know i probably i'm
thinking i have one specific instance
where i know that i did that i
was flown down to atlanta georgia at one
of the jobs i had to like
do do a meeting it made no sense for me
to go like i don't know why they sent me
there
and so i was there and i was like i am
on a business trip like it was my first
time here i am like i'm a business woman
and there's like you know this [ __ ]
coffee yeah there's like this [ __ ]
coffee i was like
of course i have to have a cup of joe
before i head out on my day
that's why i definitely that was the
time i had a hotel coffee ah
okay i will say also hotel food
breakfast and stuff my dad is is like
the king of continental breakfast
muffins nothing bad always [ __ ]
muffins come on got your muffin always
i got your muffins back let's go that's
a real dead
thanks dad always appreciate that muffin
too and it's always like a corn muffin
yeah it's nice muffin with raisins great
thanks cool thanks
he leaves with a cooler full like
chocolate chip pancake yeah
he's not the waffle maker just like
[ __ ] cooler you guys said that that
was like a
really i mean i get it doing it like if
you're going to like what you know if
you're
always visiting your friends in town
college something like that you're at
your
funeral you know something classy yeah
always a cooler maybe
there might even have been like cool
cuts in there like it depends on the
situation but
yeah always oh man for sure that is a
tough tough look
when you think about it though it sounds
nice it makes i wouldn't mind having a
cooler in my car all the time
before i went somewhere always pack a
couple of drinks a snack or two or
something like that
i think the mindset behind it is just
like i i know that my dad is someone
specifically who like doesn't like to
get ripped off and he knows that he can
buy a six-pack of budweiser
for a lot less and they're selling them
at the bar so he's like
what do you mean like i would never you
know make sense that's why they don't
come to new york
my parents never visit me it's like it
is uh yeah
tooth and nail to get them to come here
even if i'm like oh like come in like
i'll i got brunch like as long as you
guys drive in
it is literally pulling teeth to get
them here because all my dad wants to
talk about himself
but otherwise just six bucks yeah eleven
bucks for budweiser yeah there's 11
bucks
15 bucks he also he also loves to know
the i don't know
why he knows this my parents neither my
parents smoke but he knows the price of
cigarettes yeah just so we could be like
[ __ ] twenty dollar pack of cigarettes
in new york
i'm like you don't even smoke you never
have you don't even live like this
matter just trying to talk about it
where's that cooler yeah my grandfather
constantly asked every time i see him i
could see him on a tuesday and then i
see him again on a wednesday and
every time he asks me how much they
charge you for a bf4 up there
and i just lie i'm like 10 grand he's
like oh [ __ ]
like he has no [ __ ] i love the
absurdity of it they just they love to
have their minds blown with how much
like [ __ ]
that's beautiful uh all right i got
maybe let's i got
one more then i'll do a we'll do one for
the patreon uh
growing over your capri sun or juice box
family oh
i want to say both because we capri sun
capri sun was uh she's younger though
staple yeah surfer you are
cool pacific cooler the cooler but there
was also surfer cool there's
two different kinds she got mad that i
couldn't one of them has mostly water in
it one of them is like a better one for
you because my mind is i don't think
we're
yeah we're out when i was little my mom
tried to pull that [ __ ] on the kids
a couple summers ago i had to put the
kaiba
forget that like a 50 50 type thing yeah
it's
it's called what's one of the coolest
it's either surfer cooler or the other
one yeah yeah
they no we were capri sun but we also i
had um
uh you who the juice box is out the ass
so that was a
you who all day i'm living right there
your mom wrapped the hershey's chocolate
in the box
too damn yeah we're a big chocolate milk
house we're a big
milk house this is another thing too
that like whenever we gotta get it oh
this is it yeah
let's put the button okay okay you can
ask me about the milk because i got a
lot of stories about milk if you want
let's go let's go right now milk was a i
don't because
my brother and i are both like we're
thin we're small like whatever we always
we look somehow that we are malnourished
even though we weren't like we both
looked that way
and we don't understand why but when we
were younger um it was whole milk
all the time whole milk red tops milk
for dinner
milk for dinner to the point where if we
didn't finish our milk we weren't
allowed to leave the table so
i and it's milk with spaghetti milk with
pizza
yeah yeah yeah whole milk in a glass
all the way to the top like that's it
and i remember
where you've been i think back and i
remember once
the time right when we moved to
flemington my brother was still too
young so i was sitting at the kitchen
table
and i was full of like spaghetti i was
like i can't [ __ ] put anything else
in my stomach
am i both my mom was probably working or
something my dad is like he's like you
gotta finish your milk like you got it
you can't get off the table until you
finish your milk
and i was like i'm not gonna drink this
milk and so i'm sitting there and like
uh maybe at dinner at six o'clock 8 30
rolls around wow my dad
my dad had already shut the lights off
in the kitchen like he was playing his
own passive aggressive game and i was in
third grade being like no i'm not gonna
drink this [ __ ] milk it's warm
i saw like i would get to the point
where i would like look at the edges
around it be like there's like curdling
i swear to god milky way
grows two hours out sitting there and my
and then finally my dad will come in and
be like just throw it in the garbage and
like leave
you know whatever be so pissed but yeah
just milk out the ass
that's a pretty good hold on if i buy
milk now i buy i buy whole milk still
like i don't
i'll maybe buy yeah you gotta go i
rarely use it if i use i'm using it for
mac and cheese like i'm not really using
it for much else did you enjoy it for
with dinner did you like that
if you had spaghetti and meatballs did
you were like
like and enjoy it i didn't mind it for a
long time um
i think when it was like summertime i
minded it more
because it was like hot that's a bad
choice it's like i don't want a hot a
hot day
hot spaghetti and also milk like that's
that's tough
and also with pizza i hated it with
pizza but then sometimes i was able to
uh
to like finagle a little bit of soda
like i could get like some soda with my
pizza especially at like a
like a party you know or something like
that but now pretty
pretty heavy on the milk in the house
did you always pack your lunch or was it
was it bought at school um
that was pretty much 50 50 depending on
like my age and the laziness of my
parents
okay and like when i got older i never
packed my lunch but um
i know that when i was younger it was
always like i would either get peanut
butter and jelly
and like a banana or peanut butter and
jelly and like a like a little thing of
those like famous amos cookies
like one of those i don't think we've
ever you know in the [ __ ] hundred
episodes i don't think famous amos
cookies
what how is that possible i don't know i
don't have anybody with cash like
oh my god famous ain't no famous famous
those little yeah the little
snack yeah you just i haven't heard the
word famous amos yeah for 20 years
same as samus that was my [ __ ] and so i
had like little bags the little bags
that's what i would have liked the
little cookies they were always perfect
cookies
there's always a chocolate chip like
right on the corner yeah they were never
like they were chocolate chip cookies
but one cookie had one chocolate chip
like that
that was the whole thing but they're
delicious yeah famous
cookies wow okay kelly keys coming up
garbage
yeah yeah how do you feel you think so
yeah i'm confirmed
yeah what yeah i'm feeling it doesn't
matter
how many steakhouse cafeterias you went
to i figured as much i'm trying to think
of like again and that's not even like
there are so many weird stories that i
never
think of until somebody brings [ __ ] up
or like i like stuff i don't think is
weird like um
oh something i discovered today i love
liverwurst the cold cut liverwurst
and that's like something that we had
growing up all the time liverwurst honey
mustard
with red onion like on on the sandwich
wow
i don't even [ __ ] with that always
thought it was normal and then
i was like an adult and i had a
boyfriend at the time and we were or who
lived in hoboken and we were ordering
from fiori's and we were like oh
great sandwiches are not yours uh one of
the other sub
places and i was like
i was like ooh liver was sandwiched but
like all that looked to me like are you
[ __ ] serious
and i was like [ __ ] i'm serious like
order it trust me it gets a bad rap like
whatever and i got it rightfully so
i got it i was like just try it everyone
was like this is gross
like what are your house smells for like
two weeks after that's like something
you only eat because of a dare
yeah it's so good i like just so good i
like chick i like chicken livers i like
pate i like all that then you would like
liverwurst you would like liverworts i
know maybe i'm telling you
the only thing who introduced you to
that the only because that's one of the
cool cuts we always have we always had
liverwurst turkey and uh ham and roast
beef
that's not a cold cut that comes in a
tube that you have to cut at the house
true but no you cannot get it you get it
yeah
but they they slice it with within the
tube and so when you get the wrappers on
you have to pull the wrapper off of like
each piece of liverwurst yeah
oh yeah oh yeah it is it's work
it's work that is worth it that's what
you eat when you get marooned
would they send you to school with that
um no that is not something i ever i
don't i don't think
no i'm not sure i wouldn't have any
friends you wouldn't remember
pulling out a liverwurst sandwich in the
lunchroom yeah i really did buy lunch a
lot now i'm thinking about it i didn't
make lunch a lot it was a lot of buying
lunch
and and just because you know like we
get the meal car comes at you with
famous amos than liverwurst sandwiches
yeah she knows wine yeah she feels like
she dressed she dresses cool i'm like a
yeah it's
i i think i mean you're for sure i'm
definitely trash but i'm doing it very
good or i have now
been doing a video pretending yeah or
yeah pretending
i would say pretending pretending is for
sure yeah like when i'm home for sure
i'm i'm definitely trash i
another thing that i didn't think was
trash until i said something recently is
uh
water bottles in general like having
them in my house i we always
my house is just like 100 water bottles
like oh yeah not like saving the
environment like never
it's a big thing it's a case of water
always like case of water kings of water
how many of those you go through was
trashy yeah uh-huh my mom like leaves
him in the car too
oh always but that's so bad that was the
thing where where my dad would always be
can't carry him in my mom does the same
thing she's not gonna carry that up the
stairs
i know yeah yeah it's not good they get
hot and then the
the yeah they get cancer yeah they're
like
yeah yeah that's always the thing all
right i got one i got one from patreon
guys uh so when you know you're doing
the patreon we'll ask your questions
uh this is from cool kevo uh ever mixed
mountain dew with vodka
oh yeah are you kidding me mountain dew
and vodka i like mountain dew also
mountain dews is good like i feel like
it gets a bad rap like i know that it is
i know that it like literally glows in
the dark but yeah i i i i like mountain
dew dude wait
shut up but i don't even see all these
things back here
yeah this is everything we have pringles
100 of the time in my house you don't
you don't come to my house and there are
easy cheese always
there's some [ __ ] back here guess who i
have a game literally in my house right
now oh yeah yeah
oh yeah you're trash for sure i love it
it's like the princess diaries
it's half and half yeah it's my half my
life uh i got one more
who's your mom's favorite musical act oh
barry manilow i would have to say that's
a that's not that's not true that's just
that's all that's trash
she wants actually she has a she chased
barryman okay never mind
she she she loves this story will you
say check please
she loves the story she saw him either
they saw him i can't remember if they
actually went to the concert or not but
they like knew he was
somewhere and she like saw him getting
to his limo with her friend and she was
driving her like car
chased him through manhattan like
probably the last time she was in new
york literally
my mom in the 80s chased him through and
uh and like [ __ ] up her car and like
got in trouble when she got home it was
the whole thing but she
didn't get to see him like just chased
him through the streets for no reason
barry
barry i got bud heavies in the cooler
barry
oh huge barry manilow fan
what a nap kelly keegs thank you so much
this was absolutely fantastic
thank you for having me 100 garbage yeah
for sure yeah you wrote the dope europa
doped us in the beginning i was like i
don't know where this is going to go
she's kind of classy this year's house
this
that yeah you guys saying i'm well
spoken whatever yeah that's just me
repeating what i hear in movies
pretending like i didn't grow up a
little bit trash yeah i love it
fantastic
you ever fake a british accent um it
depends how
holy [ __ ] uh anything you want the folks
out there to know you got coming up
um nothing specific coming up just every
every thursday we have our because we've
got a high podcast comes out um
let's see it just goes with the alphabet
so that's why i said it's pretty fun we
just put out the l episode today we're
you know it's gonna go throughout the
rest of the alphabet and then start
right again
cool super fun subscribe to that on
youtube and for podcast youtube we're
like
i [ __ ] love youtube man yeah yeah
youtube is fantastic
i i watch i watch the [ __ ] out of some
youtube like regularly
i never used to but now that um it's
just easy you know you put it up
tv or whatever i'm watching it like
nobody's [ __ ] business like it's just
every day i'm watching
people listen in their cars and then
play it through the speakers yeah yeah
yeah that's usually how i do it too if i
listen to that
let's do a potty yeah kippy what do you
got for him uh just as always please
make sure you rate view subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
as we were just talking about and then
patreon.com guys also
live shows coming up we have raleigh in
north carolina and april 20th
zany's nashville 2021st getting some
[ __ ] texts
raleigh's tickets are moving it's
probably going to sell out so get them
soon nashville
let's [ __ ] go [ __ ] go now you're
embarrassing this out here if you're in
[ __ ] mississippi floyd i don't even
know
if you're anywhere in the south get the
national hippies getting calls from the
coast every [ __ ] two minutes
that the tickets aren't moving i got the
agents yeah what the [ __ ] make us look
good
april 21st gang we love you we'll see
you next week
peace hold on a second there partners
before you go
scurrying off out into the wild want to
talk to you one more
time about the fun time over there on
the stereo app doesn't matter whether
you have an apple
or you have a android whatever you can
sign up for free plenty of fantastic
shows plus you got me and kippy
chewing it up with you guys every
thursday nights around nine o'clock
some yeah uh it's a good time guys come
hang out it's like a little exclusive
vip
after party it's free to sign up use the
link in the description we get toward
our beaks
we look good to stereo it's a win-win
you get some free content we get a
couple of bucks
we'll see you there peace